his question comes from Ryan in Ottawa
he visits Dave Ramsey calm to ask hi
Dave currently I am on baby step number
seven and truly enjoy blessing people in
need I was recently asked by a friend to
reimburse his daughter who paid his
medical bill for his recent stay in a
hospital in Canada normally I would say
no problem but Hannes honestly I'm a
little put off that he is asking me to
pay back his daughter also he confided
in me about two years ago that he had
about a hundred thousand dollars in the
bank but that was for his kids
inheritance I do want to help here but
something feels off about it exulting is
super off about the reason it feels that
way yeah you know Dave this brings me to
a broader question about giving because
when I hear this question my first
thought is my first thing I want to see
the Ryan is do you who cares what the
guys got in the bank if you want to give
and help this person out and give and
help them out the other side of that is
what responsibility does a giver have to
chasing down all the little avenues of
how you gonna use the money and what's
going to be forward do you actually need
it
they just seems like an extra burden
that a giver is gonna carry but I also
know there's a responsibility with where
your money goes right to be a person of
good stewardship means to keep the end
in mind - yeah you got to be helpful
right and sometimes you're not being
helpful
okay what's described there in my mind
is dysfunctional yeah why does the guy
with a hundred thousand dollars in the
bank allow his daughter his own child to
pay his medical bill yeah something's
not right here that that's just that's
off Oh Ryan a guy that walks around says
I love blessing people like and then
someone says well cool you wanna pay
back my daughter right and yeah yeah
well I do love blessing people but
that's not a blessing because what
you're doing there you're not blessing
someone you're participating in their
dysfunction hmm that's like giving a
drunk a drink okay you know you're not
gonna do that so I you know I used to at
the end of the year I love blessing
people - most spenders and I'm a natural
spender aren't it's easy for us to be
generous most savers have work at the
generous muscle most the time it's not
always true but as a generality and so
I've really
always it's easy for me to tip or over
tip or give or just random acts of money
kind of thing I enjoy that and what
happened was I allocate at a percentage
of my income in addition to my tithe a
tithe to my local church has been in
addition that Shannon and I allocated a
percentage of our income to give
additionally and to various things
whatever we wanted to give to whatever
God led us to give to as Christians we
felt like we were you know called to be
outrageously generous and on and it's
good for our soul it's good for our
health it's good for everything and so
we would just pile up the money in this
percentage I just put it over a little
account yeah that percentage every time
I got money that percentage went over in
that account made this giving account
and there's a pile of money over there
yeah you get to the end the year and you
got to get rid of it because you don't
get if you don't dump it into a you know
a charity you're gonna pay taxes on it
gotcha and in my mind that money's
already gone even though it's sitting in
this separate account and so then I was
just like getting hurry and find stuff
to give it to at the end there and I'd
say okay that ministry I'm gonna send
them some money that that thing I'm
gonna send that person some money I'm
gonna do that and I would just and I was
with a bunch of wealthy guys they were
believers and one of the guys said
you're very diligent with your investing
and you are really sloppy with your
giving hmm he goes both of them are
God's money that you're managing so why
don't you invest God's money into things
that you're going to give lift to mmm
God wants to see a return on his
investment - hmm and generosity is a god
thing right so the generosity ought to
cause lift and if somebody's mismanaging
their life or their mismanaging their
ministry and you pour into it all you've
done is participate in their
mismanagement and it really convicted me
and so we got very we allocate a
percentage for just random and we don't
toss drinks to it but we don't give
substantial sums to something that we
haven't checked out because we feel like
it's investing on a kingdom level that
comes further down the funnel there to
this idea of intentionality yeah and for
a spender
on the same way I like writing big tips
it makes me feel good and and helping
people I like that especially right now
the server's haven't been working they
get back on their feet just watching
somebody light up like a light bulb
makes me light a puck right that's good
but I'd do it unintentionally and I
decide it's a couple of hundred bucks
but you start talking about several
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
or a hundred thousand dollars or
something you know you need to be wise
with right because you are making an
investment in Kingdom stuff love it and
and you know God's Spirit needs to lead
you in that you need to be compassionate
and kind but you know you can do damage
to an organization that has substantial
weaknesses when you dump a substantial
amount of money on do you not give to an
organization because you think they're
already doing well enough no no okay do
that we won't give to an organization in
case the Ramsey family foundation if
they're in debt okay or they're going to
continue to stay in debt or they're
going to continue use that as part of
their operation because we don't do that
personally and so it's inconsistent to
our value system you bet
as an example and uh and we look for
competence in the leadership team as you
should yeah so to come back to Ryan here
you know this is an incompetent toxic
situation I wouldn't fund it that's
right but just because someone has done
well and in other parts of their life
that doesn't necessarily disqualify them
from ever receiving support for me no I
won't help them yeah but it's like I
don't understand why they need why and
you go that's what's that's what's
throwing me off here it gives you a head
tilt and he even says it he says it
feels weird reason feels weird cuz it's
weird walk away that's right yeah and
it's not it's not an indication that
you're greedy or you're not generous
it's you what you don't want to support
misbehavior and cause more of it